[Musik]
helau herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
blog von mir und mein linker linker
platz frei ich wünsche mir natürlich den
hammer dabei aber nun kam somit zum 1
ja endlich da ein so begrüßung zum neuen
blog hat ist sonntag übrigens zu starten
den blog heute am sonntag gewann gestern
auch noch zeigen
ja deswegen die augenringe obwohl meine
das ist gar nicht mehr glauben zu sorgen
das ist was ich auch mal fragen rasierer
für männer und frauen
es ist eigentlich nur marketing weil die
haut ist doch gleich
naja das hat das wort zum sonntag und
heute hat essen offen ob müssen zum shop
und das ist das allerwichtigste ehrlich
das ist das allerwichtigste wir haben
nachwuchs bekommen in der familie meine
schwägerin hat ihr kind bekommen haben
sich bruder genau auch mein schwager und
schwägerin die geben wir besuchen also
heute am heutigen sonntag ist echt viel
los bei uns letztes geld geht haben wir
beide uns ein coffee to go gemacht ich
habe mein glas und du haben sie das
graffito goldenen glas und ich habe
meine tore glaube ich ja aus porzellan
aber wir sollten uns schlechten zweiten
hude ist wo sie anfallen wir verkaufen
im shop und haben nur einen einzigen zu
hause also ihr kennt mich ja
mittlerweile ich bin ja ein kaffee trank
nie aber noch wenn es um maximal cetto
geht ja also nur mit ganz viel milch und
ich hatte immer das problem dass ich
keine guten to go becher gefunden haben
weil in den stall schmeckt komisch aus
glas nähe hat mir auch nicht gefallen
viele den geschmack ein bisschen
verändert jetzt haben wir die aus
porzellan und mache ich jetzt nicht
draufhauen erst einmal gebaut hat man
auch mal eine decke auf machthaber
ich hab dich erkannt ja ich war auch gut
so
die haben sich dann nur so
bis gleich
übrigens unsere aktuellen goodison ist
gerade im shop ist hiervon ruf das sind
richtig coole produkte hier bio
zitronenschale orangenschale haben wir
auch dann je nach dem was sie eben
erwischt
das ist halt immer zufallsprinzip gibt
es hier trinkt porridge richtig cool und
wir haben aktuell in jedem paket auch
noch unsere beliebten haben sich schon
am nassen ich auch immer wenn ich im
shop in essig mindestens einen sockel
gestellt
zuvor haben sie die erde weg ist gibt es
natürlich auch ein paket bei uns zu
kaufen und ich versuche auch immer
wieder neue produkte reinzubringen für
das servieren zum beispiel hierfür
oliven oder weiß ich nicht beim
frühstück dass er da verschiedene sachen
drauf gibt gemüse zum beispiel oder käse
einrollen richtig schick also versuchen
uns echt immer zu erweitern sind jetzt
doch freunde
im anschluss wieder fahren wenn ich den
menschen demnächst also ein paar greife
ich dann von dir ab so wieder zu hause
und meiner meinung nach kann man sich
den film im kino echt sparen also die
handlung war irgendwie so ein bisschen
vorhersehbar was sowieso ein remake war
das perfekte geheimnis und ja aber so zu
entspannen ganz okay also eben nicht so
dieses hollywood-blockbuster feeling was
man so hat im kino
na ja ich gehe auf jeden fall schlafen
und morgens montag nennen sehen wir uns
morgen früh wieder also gute nachdem ich
bin guten morgen ich gehe jetzt erst mal
zur post ein paar pakete abgeben zum
teil gewinner zum teil einfach pakete
zum beispiel für mein netzwerk oder für
partner und das mache ich jetzt und
danach wird gefrühstückt
jetzt drehen wir die kokons opel gehabt
im letzten block gesehen weil die sind
so gut die sind so lecker und easy peasy
gestellt da haben sie doch sofort man
das video dazu gedreht wo bin ich von
dem brauch ich fühle mich geehrt dass
ich habe sogar in die küchenmaschine
macht auch schon party die denken dann
geht's los hier ich will endlich rühren
diese effekte rein
allerdings effekte übrigens echt mega
gern lockere oberteil nicht mag das
nicht wenn es hauteng ist und will
sparen weil in diesem video trage ich
meine schütze am anfang noch nicht weil
da ist er kenne klecker gefahren also
ich meine die küchenmaschine und deshalb
bleibe ich jetzt ist ohne ohne schütze
habe auslaufen wie viele wie viele
kommentare wie kriegen ob ich schwanger
bin
was glaubst du gewusst weil mein
oberteil so zur lok heizt und sicher
auch noch mit baby hat weil ich so hieß
es im dezember gegessen habe die sache
ist
ja die nicht richtig zuhören sei auch du
musst du echt so viele fragen mich das
weiß ich einfach auch mit echten linke
gerne local time und trage und manchmal
guckt wieder die bilder an den ja klar
kann sich darunter einen babybauch
verstehen darunter kann sie aber auch
ein feedback verstecken
es geht alles egal ich kann jetzt leider
nicht in das spiel reingehen weil wir
gerade hier so ein zeitraffer aufnehmen
und nahm mich hier sieht hh auf jeden
fall kann ich jetzt nicht ins bild kommt
kiki ist einfach warten und kiki ist
einfach wollten riss der woche mit der
stirn
thema ist auch nicht gerade story
gemacht
ich weiß nicht warum es geht aber ich
kenne dich mal auf worum es geht ist ja
auch nicht schlimm ist aber das finde
ich viel schlimmer ich weiß es nicht ich
[Musik]
nehme euch mal mit
danke für den kaffee wobei jetzt eine
doofe reihenfolge jetzt dringlich kaffee
und direkt danach er sich mittagessen es
gibt übrigens nudeln mit ton fischsauce
oh ich hab das einfachste mittagessen
jetzt etwas auf der welt existiert aber
es schmeckt halt geschmeckt und heute
nämlich sogar rote linsen nudeln
gerichtlich viel also der richtige
eiweiß bombe
[Musik]
ich war extra geübt
händler meinen kochkursen ist echt okay
das ist jetzt strecken noch ein
bosnisches rezept fühlen dann meine
wunderschöne frau für diesen leckeren
kuchen und ich muss jetzt hier noch ein
bisschen aufräumen ihnen mich macht das
wahnsinnig ich schmeiße kartons weg und
ist ja alles gut aber ich schmeiße
kartons kisten kartons ich jetzt sagen
wieder kartons bekommen ja neue kartons
ich krieg die krise ist noch nicht mal
irgendwie online bestellen oder so
gemein ist dass sie schon auflaufformen
die gerade gesehen hat zum anderen
endlich so seine schüssel satin in ganz
ganz groß habe ich heute benutzt hier
und den rest verrate ich noch nicht da
müsst ihr einfach mal gedulden aber im
letzten block habe ich euch gesagt dass
wir gerade eine neue sache erfinden und
es ist echt so dass gerade in produktion
geht ich hab gedacht ich kann euch in
diesem blog schon ein bisschen mehr dazu
erzählen aber ich möchte es wirklich
erst freuen wenn du gemäss boller sitzt
nicht ich wollte das erst wenn es auch
wirklich bei uns im online shop
politiker
das ding ist einfach genial strecken
sind zwei dinge aber das eine ist
einfach neuheit so ich habe es aufgrund
ganz alleine picobello picobello fast
bekommen
doch sprecher jetzt ist die wohnung
aufgeräumt und ich wollte eigentlich
noch was verlosen sagt er dann natürlich
verlose einen unserer tortenplatte
bestseller nämlich die farbe grau
ansonsten ist auch noch bestseller rosa
und weiß und mittelblocker denke rosa
und blau kommt daher weil es dann für
baby shower partys genutzt wird oder
generell für mädels und jungs
geburtstage ich möchte es gerne neutral
halten daher einmal die graue
tortenplatte und das ist alles haben wir
da steht noch heute unsere sechs
erholungsbewegung zu schöner
präsentieren unsere 67 sie kommen daher
in einer eleganten löffel form man kann
sich vielseitig verwenden zb für den
kopf oder für seine hatte oder
süßigkeiten ins web firma besucht da ist
ihr sollte ich auf jeden fall in den
oster- oder so oder saucen und dips und
so echt schön
ihr bekommt natürlich alles nagelneu
wackernagel verpackt aus unserem shop
genau und was ist zu tun um mitzumachen
schreibt doch einfach mal in die
kommentare
für noch keine ahnung wie wir sagt ende
teilt uns doch einfach mit was ihr an
silvester macht dann ist es ja nicht
mehr lange in circa einer woche haben
soll
teilt uns doch einfach mit was ihr
schönes an silvester treibt erzählt von
ihren plänen und dann hüpft die
automatischen stop und konnten wir auch
im salon kommst du mit dem hammer auf
instagram somit und mir auch dass die
teilnahmebedingungen aber ja wohl
verpasst echt wir sehen uns da nicht
folgt sondern jetzt sind lasse ich euch
heute ist der block nicht so lang aber
ihr habt ihr gesehen was heute so abging
und gestern verletzten seien auch immer
drei tage heute wieder kommt zwei tage
reichen
und vielleicht starte ich einen neuen
flug vielleicht auch nicht wir schauen
einfach mal was so los ist im alltag und
am sagt er wir hoffen natürlich dass
euch der block gefallen hat
im kino oder möchten sie noch was dann
kommt man kommt so groß ist wenn ich so
weit vorne bin folgt uns erwartet uns
teilt uns leicht uns ist die schweiz
nicht nur ja ich verstehe was sage ich
mich etwas sagen ich möchte etwas sagen
also versuchst das video auf zehn
minuten zu stricken es ist schon
überzogen
[Musik]
na ja auf jeden fall wiedersehen auf
wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
ihr seht den block und direkt am
nächsten tag kommt mein köster rezept
mit einer geheim- zutat online hat es
wird schön dass morgen das video genau
kommentiert fleißig hinterlassen ganz
viel aktivität damit muss pushen ja
ansonsten noch einen wunderschönen tag
und wir sehen uns dann locker